The Wall Street Journal reports at Fox
News is preparing to cut ties with its
star host Bill O'Reilly Fox News and The
Wall Street Journal are both controlled
by the Murdoch family the report comes
amid growing sexual harassment
allegations against Bill O'Reilly an
attorney for him claims that he quote
has been subjected to a brutal campaign
of character assassination and her
Warner's outside Fox News headquarters
here in New York and a good morning good
morn good morning bill o'reilly last
appeared on air on april eleventh when
he announced he was taking a pre-planned
vacation the question now is whether
that vacation could become permanent
kausha you are about to enter thee no
spin zone but perhaps for not much
longer as Bill O'Reilly future at Fox
News appeared to grow increasingly
uncertain on Tuesday you're right actors
on tonight New York magazine reports the
Murdoch family which controls Fox News
parent company 21st Century Fox is split
on what to do about O'Reilly James and
Lachlan Murdoch are in favor of
dismissing him but their father Rupert
has resisted because as the magazine put
it it would make him appear he was
forced into a decision by the New York
Times this is a real test of whether or
not Rupert Murdoch is really going to
let them run the company the success of
Fox News was in large part built on the
shoulders of Bill O'Reilly would be a
difficult situation for any family when
you add billions of dollars at stake and
influence and power on April first the
New York Times revealed that O'Reilly
and Fox paid up to 13 million dollars to
settle accusations of sexual harassment
or other inappropriate behavior by
o'reilly against five women since then
more than 50 major advertisers have
pulled commercials from o'reilly
top-rated program and protesters have
gathered outside Fox News headquarters
calling for the hosts firing the
pressure ramped up on Tuesday when
another woman who has remained anonymous
reported new harassment allegations
against O'Reilly to 21st Century Fox
according to her attorney Lisa bloom
Bill O'Reilly worked near her he would
come by her desk when there was no one
around and make sexually inappropriate
comments to her an attorney for O'Reilly
calls the claim outrageous and says his
firm has uncovered evidence
that the smear campaign is being
orchestrated by far left organizations
bent on destroying O'Reilly for
political and financial reasons he
really has a big voice in the culture
and certainly on that Network and it's
not going to be easy for them to fill
those shoes 21st Century Fox has
declined to comment on all of this
following the resignation of former Fox
News chairman Roger Ailes last year amid
similar allegations Fox promised a
zero-tolerance policy on sexual
harassment Nora all right Anna thank you
I wonder will get a development on this
I think in the next several days I do
too I don't think it's we're going to
know one way or the other very very soon
or anything